just four days from now moving on the
leaders of North and South Korea will
hold the first summit between the two
countries in more than a decade I had
that meeting North Korean leader Kim
jong-un announced that his government
would suspend tests of nuclear weapons
and long-range missiles a new book
us-versus-them the failure of globalism
looks at some of the consequences of
increased international connections
author Ian Bremmer discusses growing
nationalism around the world and support
for anti-establishment politicians in as
a CBS News senior global affairs
contributor and president of the Eurasia
group you welcome congratulations on the
block's
but before that II and you have to tell
us how you feel about the Royal baby I'm
glad that there are ten figures in ten
toes okay that's what you want in a
situation that is what you want yeah a
good global story right now and now the
pivot from royal babies to North Korea
yeah what do you make of the messages
coming out of North Korea right now they
are giving us a continued cease of
testing both of ICBMs and nukes we are
giving them a summit that is not new
news last week it both been announced a
month ago it's been reiterated they're
talking about denuclearization it's not
actually going to happen but I think
that Trump is one of those guys that if
he gets five percent of what he wants
his ability to spin that into this is
the best deal that humanity has ever
seen and I deserve a Nobel is fairly
high so he is getting progress and I
think at least in the near term this is
becoming a bigger opportunity so that's
interesting but but there is this red
line of do they have a nuclear program
or not and the administration has said
they don't want them to have any nuclear
program so can he still do the five
percent end zone dance if the nuclear
program is still in existence in any
form my I think that Trump said a lot of
things that he has changed his mind on
once it becomes politically expedient
and this will be one of those things
remember the Israel Palestine peace plan
was one that he and Jared were going to
do I have not heard them discussed that
in months now because they've tilted
towards North Korea this is now the
priority and Kim jong-un is playing a
little ball with them right so I think
the summit is going to happen
Pompeyo was over there he didn't make
any demands
the North Koreans which is another thing
you see that they really don't want me
to make it uncomfortable make it easy
for Kim jong-un to come to this meeting
and announce that they've done something
that no other president has ever done
sat down with Kim jong-un that's a big
deal Trump deserves a win for it let's
hope he doesn't break it China was once
considered essential for the talks with
North Korea's now they're largely on the
sidelines what changed they have had
their own summit already with Kim
jong-il and Kim made a point of going to
Beijing first and Xi Jinping is going to
Pyongyang to make it very clear that at
the end of the day the entire North
Korean economy is dependent on the
Chinese and if there's going to be a
deal it's gonna have to be blessed by
China look if the Americans start
pulling troops out of South Korea as
part of any deal and the South Koreans
are working to do a peace deal with the
North Koreans
the Chinese end up in a better position
on all of this long-term than the
Americans do and let's talk about us
versus them because you said Trump did
not create us versus them US versus them
created Trump who you described as
obnoxious dishonest and incompetent but
do not dismiss his supporters of which
you say your brother is one oh
absolutely I mean look I think across
the country we see a lot of people that
have gotten really angry because free
trade has not worked for them right open
borders and changing the composition of
the country has not worked for them
endless failed wars in Vietnam Iraq
Afghanistan Syria have not worked for
them and they've paid the ultimate price
as enlisted men and women and now
technology is not working for them and
the idea that we're going to blame
people that voted for Trump as opposed
to a much larger group of people that
didn't bother to vote at all 40 or 45 as
opposed to the you know so that much
small group the Trump and Hillary got or
we're going to not blame the people that
sat by and voted for establishment
figures like the Clintons like the
bushes for decades while people in the
country got so angry and so displaced
that they felt like the only thing they
could do was vote for someone like Trump
Ellucian well in the near term let's
recognize that getting rid of Trump is
not going to solve this in the same
because it's not just happening in the
u.s. it's happening all across Europe we
saw the elections in Italy we saw the
elections in Germany we saw the brexit
vote we saw the elections in Hungary
like this
is not just an American crowd but the
only country you don't see it is in
Japan where they don't take any
immigrants with a population shrinking
okay you remember to understand the
trends going on in politics read
us-versus-them thanks so much for being
with us us the it's hits bookstores
tomorrow
in fact so we've posted an excerpt on
CBS this morning dot-com